hey everyone we're in the middle of San
Diego comic-con 2018 with lots of big
trailers dropping by the minute and so
far the one everyone right is talking
about is Titans on the DC streaming
service that's coming up and more on
that and soon we will talk all about
that but welcome to new rockstars news
it's our deep dive into all the biggest
stories to come out this week and so
we're gonna talk about the Walking Dead
Season 9 trailer the Joker origin movie
birds of prey news about James Gunn and
spider-man far from home I am Erik Voss
and joining me at this table are oh it's
just me today everyone else is actually
at Comic Con I had to stay behind to
break down all the trailers as they come
out online so but that's fine oh this is
you know essentially what I spend my
free time doing in just sitting alone
and pretending my best friends are here
with me and talking to myself and their
voices what's that mud Oh Sam Philip is
nuts not right but you know it's just
gonna be a long time with boss and it's
gonna get weird and for those who tuned
in hoping to fill a void with some kind
of imaginary SourceFed nerd 2.0 don't
worry cuz you're gonna love me cuz
you're stuck with me but you know let's
get started with our top story the
trailer for DC series Titans now Titan
said one of the first big trailers at
Comic Con this year and it made a very
bold statement one that we can't repeat
here but the conex version of titans or
it's also known as teen titans was led
by Dick Grayson Robin and several other
younger versions of the main DC Justice
League heroes there's been kind of a
rotating lineup over the years this
series will follow an adult Grayson
played by Brenton Thwaites he's a
detective and a violent Street vigilante
and his days as Batman's sidekick are
well behind them he angrily Chuck's his
Robin R into the wall and he growls
Batman bleep that please now that sounds
like a line that he stole from our
Marvel fan commenters anytime we talk
about Ben Affleck the series will also
star Tegan Croft as Rachel Roth aka
Raven she's a haunted empath
the daughter of a demon Ana Diop as
coriander aka Starfire an alien princess
who can shoot energy bolts she can fly
as well
and Ryan Potter as gar Logan okay Beast
Boy is like green scanning can
shape-shift ndon any animal and Geoff
Johns has also confirmed that fan
favorite characters like Jason Todd and
Donna Troy Donna Troy will also be
featured in the show along with a bunch
of other characters and yeah this
trailer definitely ain't family-friendly
folks there's violence there's blood
there's grit I kind of hate it when
people say things like it's gritty we
get them from the south so whenever
people say gritty it just sounds like
the DP smeared grits on the lens greats
have no place on a set or in your mouth
was a great joke right everybody yeah
now when to when asked to explain Robin
hating on batman geoff johns explained
if you look at when robin first left
batman the comics there was a lot of
uneasiness in him being lost titans is
really a series about these different
characters that are all just lost in
their lives just like the greatest comic
book titans run ever by Marv Wolfman and
George Perez it's about all these lost
characters find him one another and
they're all struggling with something
and Robin is clearly struggling with his
past with Batman and we'll learn a lot
about more about it and what that is and
why he is the way he is okay to me this
looks like DC just wants its own
equivalent to what Marvel has with the
Netflix universe right a darker and
tonal alternative to the family-friendly
action in the movies and the major TV
networks but Jonathas also said the show
will take inspiration from the original
Titans TV series which ran in the 60s he
said really the DNA of it is in the echo
of the original series because it had so
much drama and in that and it was so
revolutionary for its time which is true
we really wanted to lean into the idea
that every Titan of these Titans is
doorway into another genre with Rachel
that's Raven it's supernatural and the
horror and the first seasons really
focus on who Raven is and how the Titans
galvanize around her and you can see
that tone in the trailer clearly now
personally I'm really excited for like a
DC Universe streaming service and for
you know better
where Satan's looks like I promising
enough flagship series for it now I
don't totally understand this idea of
doorways to other genres within one TV
series to me that sounds like some tonal
inconsistencies I kind of want a TV
series to have one consistent tone
throughout and feel like it's all part
of one world rather than like every
episode is kind of a different world
that sounds more like an anthology
series to me which is its own great
thing and Titans could be a great in
Thal geez but it's it's just the first
teaser trailer there's still a lot to
learn about what this series will be and
you know for those were complaining
about Robyn saying that line about
Batman I don't personally hold dick
Grayson's innocence to be like sacred
like the classic Boy Wonder reputation
is why a lot of INSAS of like
historically rolled their eyes of the
character even though they shouldn't and
really Grayson's evolution into the solo
vigilante Nightwing was always more
exciting than me at least
so anything that brings the character
closer to that incarnation I can get
behind
but yeah the jury is still out on this I
want to know what you guys think about
this trailer do you think that they are
kind of missing the mark with what Robin
is supposed to be and what Titans is
supposed to be and just to remind you it
will air on the DC Universe streaming
service this fall so you know you can
start saving up that $8 a month because
that's what it's gonna cost you it's
going after Netflix I'll see how well it
does but okay some breaking news that
just came out this afternoon it was
reported that director James Gunn has
been removed from guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 it wasn't officially
announced that he would be the director
but he is the writer the director of it
and he hasn't really been keeping that a
secret but he is no longer the decision
was made after it was revealed that Gunn
had made some particularly racy jokes on
Twitter in years past there's a lot of
different ones that you can go read
different articles to see some of them
have made jokes about things like rate
and pedophilia it was really just
designed for him to like push the
envelope and he was trying to be a
provocateur in today's context it kind
of looks a pretty alarming but he is
kind of he's apologized you know he said
he's for a long time been a bit of a
provocateur that's what he was was
trying to do in the past but it's he
regrets posting these things and you
know if you follow James Gunn
Twitter in recent months especially he
has gotten particularly political and
he's gotten in debates in a lot of with
a lot of people disagree with him and
some of these enemies of him have
unearthed a lot of these tweets and it
seems like they've done it as a result
of his political disagreements with
people so look as I said he's apologized
and it's a very very new story there's
still a lot coming out so I don't want
to draw any conclusions or jump the gun
I'm sorry inappropriate joke guys guys
stop the applause it wasn't that kind of
a Chuck but yeah we'll learn more about
this as it comes out it's kind of delves
into like more like scandal celebrity
gossip news that we don't normally do on
this channel but I just want to update
you because he's an important person
that we all have been following okay
everyone the Walking Dead's ninth season
released a trailer at Comic Con today
and this thing is a beast it's 5 minutes
and 44 seconds of footage from the first
half of season 9 which will premiere on
October 7th
now before I run through this footage
and breakdown the details that you may
have missed just to remind you guys it
has been confirmed that Rick Andrew
Lincoln and Maggie lauren cohan will
exit the show in this first half of the
season so a lot of what we're gonna be
looking at is ways for the show to kind
of wind down what their characters arcs
are and we started to see a bit of that
in this footage so let's dive into it ok
the trailer opens with Rick and negan
chatting in the prison cell now the
comics feature a huge time jump right
after the all-out war storyline against
negan after that ends up and so the show
Season 9 seems to be doing that as well
it shows Rick with his big bushy beard
he has a short hair that reflects
exactly what his character looks like at
this point in the comics and in the
first issue back it does end with Rick
walking down into the prison cell and
talking with negan so they do kind of
have these like long chats about the
nature of humanity and is it is Rick's
philosophy really right is it justified
and it's some of the more interesting
panels from these issues of the comics
I'm glad the show is working this in we
also see Maggie at the hilltop now she
now has her baby finally after like 18
months of pregnancy but the hilltop has
constricted lots of medieval technology
if you look in the background a lot of
like wood based instruments there's also
a windmill that you can see now she was
actually given the blueprints for a lot
of this technology
including this windmill from Georgie
last season if you look closely at this
windmill you can see what looks like the
word Commonwealth now that could be just
like a street sign but of course the
Commonwealth is a new location from the
comics and a lot of us believe that
Georgie was from the Commonwealth that
she could have been the show's version
of Pamela who leads the the Commonwealth
in comics it's a really advanced
community it's very militarized they
have like kind of stormtrooper like
guards and they have like an
amphitheater and just they're a very
advanced community so we're thinking
that Pamela could be Georgie on the show
and that's where she's from more on that
in a second there is also a shot of the
gang exploring an interior location with
white columns and a big staircase which
looks a lot like a place from the
Smithsonian and Washington DC or maybe
some government building there in the
background is a crumbling crumbling
facade of the US Capitol building when
they're outside so my guess is the
survivors are scavenging this horse
carriage from a DC museum maybe the
Museum of national history or of there's
probably one of like transportation
right so that's why I'm guessing that
we're gonna be looking at here there's
also a shot of a camp that all the
survivors kind of live in with a
signpost and the different signs show HQ
Oceanside Alexandria sanctuary and
Toledo
I'm guessing Toledo is just a joke since
you know it's pretty far west from where
they are maybe there's some new
characters from Toledo or they're just
kind of giving you a sense of north
south east and west but the interesting
thing to me here is what community is
missing right the hilltop is missing so
my assumption is that HQ refers to the
hilltop so the hilltop being considered
the HQ the center of operations
basically suggests that it's replaced
Alexandria as the main base of all these
characters which could be some source of
tension between Rick and Maggie remember
there was a scene at the end of last
season where Maggie seemed to be
conspiring against Rick and they're kind
of laying some groundwork for potential
conflict in the future that some of us
had some mixed feelings about and if you
watching this trailer there is a lot of
shots where there's some intergroup
rivalry and restlessness and people
having trouble forgiving each other but
more on that in a bit there's also a
very interesting shot that shows
someone's boots staggering on the ground
as whoever is walking in these it's
bleeding out now considering Rick only
has six episodes left we could be
looking at him here but we'll see more
of that as we get into the season
there's also a quick shot of Jadis on
the radio with the helicopter behind her
now remember we saw her character trying
to some in a helicopter last season and
this one has the same exact symbol on
the side of it I speculated that this
helicopter could be from the
Commonwealth
like the one advanced society that we
know who exists in this area who has
lots of different technology and they
scavenge a lot and they've done very
well for themselves she could have some
kind of connection with Georgie but I
assume this is the same helicopter and
she's trying to connect with them again
so it's looking like season 9 we'll go
more into that arc and one of the more
intriguing details from this trailer is
a series of graffiti words tagged on the
walls like saviors save us and final
warning
now saviors save us probably refer to
more that unsettled rivalry between the
groups maybe that some of the different
groups don't trust Rick's leadership and
want to go back to the way things were
under negan but final warning is
interesting it looks like that could be
from a group called the whisperers now
that's a new enemy group from the comics
set we have been on the lookout for I
feel like back in season 5 people are
looking in the bushes and be like I saw
whisperer
I saw whisperer but yeah they're a group
who has a very like tribal mindset and
they do issue a very very very serious
warnings to Rick's people in a way that
I don't want to spoil but yeah they're
very like this is our side that's your
side don't come near us so final warning
seems like it could be from them but we
also see a bunch of the new characters
into this season including Magna now in
the comics Magna is the leader of a
small group from Richmond who first
shows up right after the all-out war
ends she is on the cover of the new
beginning arc of the comics and she's
Dan but she's joined by Dan Fogler from
the fantastic beasts movies he plays a
character in this group as well but the
craziest detail guys hold on to your
butts it comes in the final few seconds
when Rosita in Eugene are hiding and
they're trembling in fear they're
covering themselves in mud as a group of
walkers pass by them but guys these are
not walkers these actually are whispers
and this is the crazy steel detail took
me forever to actually hear this but Ida
listened to it over and over again
listen precisely at 5 minutes and 15
seconds very very closely turned the
volume on your headphones you can hear
one of them rasp but very slowly where
it's very very chilling and it's one of
the creepier moments from the comics as
well if you if you read the comics they
think that they hear Walker's talking to
each other but that's how we find out
that the whispers exists and as I
mentioned there they're basically just a
tribe of weirdos whose skin walkers and
they wear the Walker skins to disguise
themselves and they whisper to each
other to try to like blend in and that's
how they protect themselves that's how
they attack other people and when the
whisperers arrive on the scene they are
a huge huge huge game changer so it's
one of the things I'm very very excited
to see in season 9 overall I think this
trailer was really well edited it's
really excited got me legitimately
pumped for season 9 the camerawork and
the horror imagery seems like a big step
up from past seasons I'm Angela King
seems like she is the right person for
the job to lead this show at least based
off of this trailer and for sure the
Whisperer is joining the fray it's
definitely something we can all look
forward to it's a really really fun arc
in the comics now I just have to admit
that the heavy focus on inter-community
conflicts just worries me like the past
seasons have I think spent too much time
in creating and manufacturing these
conflicts between characters who
shouldn't be fighting and season eights
finale
included that super unnecessary scene
with Maggie conspiring against Rick with
Jesus it just seemed completely out of
character for all of them I agree that
in writing conflict is important you
have to have characters who like
disagree with each other otherwise
there's like no drama and there's no
point to watching the scene I just don't
know if we need more of in more and more
episodes like entire episodes with
manufactured hissy fits right there they
aren't real drama between groups who
have overwhelmingly mutual interests
like I get a conflict between the
Savior's and others and I get the
conflict between Rick and potentially
the whispers and between the walkers but
like just I have characters who are
essentially on the same side randomly
pick a fight with each other just to
fill 44 minutes of runtime is one of the
bigger problems that they've had on The
Walking Dead in the past few years so
looks like just based off of the this
five minutes of footage that they're
gonna be doing more of that so it
doesn't make me totally look forward to
season 9 especially when - the main
characters are moving on I
I don't really know what the direction
is going forward yet but I will be
assured that to keep an eye on I'm gonna
keep watching it I just can't promise
that we're gonna do as in-depth episode
by episode breakdowns on this channel
because it seems like fewer and fewer of
you guys to even care about it and it
takes a ton of resources for us right
guys right yes yes agreed agreed I don't
even watch a show what's walking Ted it
just takes a lot for us to devote weekly
videos and do specific episodes of a
series because you kind of imagine like
four episodes and how many people really
watch that episode and how what
percentage of them are gonna watch our
videos on it so it's just hard for us to
commit like days of our time to do this
when there's other big things that you
guys probably care more about but anyway
comment down below with your thoughts on
this trailer I don't want to hate on too
much because I really did like this
trailer and it did give me more hope for
season 9 than I thought I would have at
this point but for now let us move on to
another quick update that came out this
week this one about the Joker origin
movie Joaquin Phoenix confirmed that he
will be starring in the upcoming Joker
origin film and we now know that this
early version of the man who becomes a
joker will be named Arthur Fleck now
that's not any known alias of the Joker
in the DC Comics is a brand new
character named and they're doing the
origin story it sounds like they're
gonna be going in the direction of an
80s failed comedian which sounds a lot
like his backstory in The Killing Joke
except there wasn't the 80s director
Todd Phillips will begin shooting this
movie this fall and it has a release
date of October 4th 2019 it was reported
that ZZ beats from Deadpool 2 in Atlanta
will be joining the cast of this movie
in an unnamed role they had like a
casting description that went out but we
don't know much about what her character
will be oh and speaking of DC villain
news the Harley Quinn led DC team up
movie birds-of-prey has announced its
character lineup margot robbie of course
will reprise Harley Quinn after she
played in Suicide Squad and she will be
joined by Black Canary
that's Dinah Laurel she's a crime
fighter known for handy in combat
Huntress aka Helena Bertinelli and she's
at Gotham vigilante Cassandra Cain a
martial arts expert and Renee Montoya a
Gotham detective who actually is lately
in the comics taken on a costume
identity known as the question very
interesting so the villain actually was
previously announced as the penguin but
now it sounds like it will be a deceive
that has never been on screen before at
least in the big screen so I'm kind of
interested to see who this could be MIDI
Clayface we've seen Killer Croc and
Suicide Squad so let me know who you
think that villain of birds of prey will
be or who you would like it to be and a
one final quick update to come out of
this week
spider-man far from home announced that
the movie cast Turkish actor Newman a
car as a character named Dmitri now we
don't know much else about the role
other than his first name but in the
spider-man comics Dmitri murder Cove is
the name of the villain chameleon now
the chameleon is a master of disguise
some versions of the villain have given
him like shape-shifting powers but the
original end actually technically the
most recent version are more practical
characters they wear masks of people's
faces and they just like impersonate
their voice and and mannerisms perfectly
which i think is a bit more interesting
to go in the granite direction in this
case now a car joins j.b smoove who has
been cast in the sequel as well along
with possibly Jake Gyllenhaal who is
still currently rumored to be playing
Mysterio but just to remind you that has
not been in confirmed yet so we'll give
you more details about spider-man far
from home as they come out and yeah
there are more and more updates coming
out from Comic Con as we're talking as
you're watching this video there may be
a new trailer out we're still kind of
playing catch-up and we will be breaking
down everything all the big stuff but
continue to tweet us to see what
trailers and what you want to know more
about from the updates that you see this
weekend but for now let us move on to
new rockstars news lightning round now
this is a you know interesting situation
because normally we get tweets from you
guys and I have to like fire them my
co-host I'm really I don't really have a
coast I mean there's Boba Fett back
there and oh yeah there's Groot so these
are my friends now I'm in the land of
misfit toys where I belonged oh yeah and
finding out it's back here we just
wanted to surround myself with things
that make me comfortable um but they
can't answer because they aren't real
they're only real in my imagination and
sometimes in my vision when I haven't
taken my medication but for now I guess
I'll just take all the questions that
that we've compiled from what you guys
would tweet us sound good okay uh here
we go at small gentleman wants to know
what's the worst ad for a good movie or
vice versa
had so I assumed by a demon trailer and
I'm gonna say for the worst trailer for
the worst trailer for a good movie
probably first one to come of mine would
be spider-man homecoming yeah because
that was like a good movie that I that I
liked it's just a trailer kind of
revealed too much and kind of included
some of the moments that made me a
little worried about the movie it wasn't
the worst trailer in the world but it's
just one that comes to mind and then the
best trailer for the worst movie was
probably Suicide Squad that's like the
example that always comes to mind like
what an amazing trailer that bohemian
rhapsody' trailer was dope but the movie
was pretty pretty rough but I mean if
we're talking about advertising to
marketing in general I mean the movie
edge of tomorrow that came out a couple
years ago the Tom Cruise movie directed
by Mission Impossible director Chris
McQuarrie or maybe he just wrote it
anyway it's an amazing movie that I
think just suffered from bad marketing
like they called it edge of tomorrow and
later in DVD release they called it live
die repeat which i think is a much more
apt title that gives you a sense of what
the movie is but yeah that's a movie
that like should have performed better
but just like marketing could have used
a bit more attention to detail anyway
moving on next question at Brendan
Matthew wants to know yo the talkative
one you can decide which is which here
guys even though it's the one in the
middle I guess that's me I don't know
which one you would you prefer reading
The Game of Thrones books or listening
to the audiobook
I'm only talkative cuz I have to like
read the copy you know I don't know if
you noticed that like as soon as like I
finished setting up the topic I
immediately want the other host away and
but I guess technically you're right if
you're doing word count breakdown I'm
probably talking more especially this
episode I mean I've been hearing lots of
voices but you can't hear them because
you're not in my head yeah
Boba Fett's mad because his movie got
cancelled and in groots you know he's
upset about other current events too
it's just too soon to talk about anyway
might answer a question I would say read
the books you know we don't read enough
books the audiobooks again with roads
are awesome don't get me wrong but like
yeah train your eyes read books we
should all just be reading things on
pages more I think it's it's better for
our minds and it makes you look smarter
okay at I am the curve once
- no would you rather fight a hulk-sized
Thor or tenth or sized Hulk's I would
say one Hulk size Thor because at least
he's still destructible whereas the Hulk
isn't and he'd probably be clumsy
because the Hulk's not used to having or
the Thor it's not used to having the
Thor he's not used to whatever you get
it okay I'll take one more
at capi kid wants to know what's the
worst haircut you ever had oh I actually
have a good story for this one Philip
would be great to tell this story but
when we're in college we did a sketch
show right Philip yeah it was my
birthday yesterday and I'm doing other
stuff today belated birthday to me
anyway as it was his birthday history we
did a sketch show where he was Steve
Jobs or I was Steve Jobs and I had to UM
shave my head because I don't know we
had to commit to our characters
appearances and Philip shaved it and not
only did he shave it he shaved a
receding hairline in my head in a bald
spot because he wanted it to look more
accurate which was you know I'll commit
to the part but I was just unfortunately
stuck with this weird haircut that was
just growing back weird for like a month
maybe two months and in the week after
this actually it was our first visit to
Los Angeles to decide if we wanted to
move here so I was hanging out with all
my cool la friends and their even cooler
friends with his dumb haircut including
Donald Glover was a was a friend of a
friend and this is before he really blew
up and we were all hanging out in a
group and I was walking right beside him
on Franklin and I this stupid haircut
and I was self-conscious about the whole
time that's the worst haircut I've ever
had second and right now because I'm
self-conscious about it anyway all right
next up let's take a look at what we got
in the pipeline for videos coming out on
the channel next week by the way thank
you to everyone who tweeted us and for
people who don't have time to get to
your watch and we'll get to it next week
if we can but anyway next week in the
pipeline guys it's one of the biggest
weeks of the year it's Comic Con so
we'll be looking at trailers for Aquaman
and Shazam and if we see it venom and
Wonder Woman 1984 also sounds like we
might get a trailer for fantastic beasts
crimes of Grindelwald and the movie
glass whatever we have time to break
down we're gonna try to get to it as
fast as we can and get some interesting
breakdowns that catch everything that
you might have missed from these
trailers so just keep an eye out on our
Channel
also on Wednesday we'll be released
our breakdown of the Dark Knight Rises
our rewatching our breakdown you guys
have been so supportive and checking out
the Dark Knight's breakdown and the
Batman Begins breakdown it's been one of
my favorite series to do I think we've
all put a ton of work into it we're all
very proud of it so yeah keep an eye out
it's not as long as the Dark Knight
video but I did find some really cool
stuff that I didn't catch the first
couple times that I watched it so keep
an eye out for that and now comes the
time for our 15-second shout out or
normally each of us when I 15 seconds to
shout out plug or ramble about anything
we want since just me I'll just take
each of the 15 seconds oh and I do have
some things that I want to shout out
okay first off I saw the movie started
to bother you last weekend which i think
is great if it's played in your area go
watch it it's like it's got what's his
face he's from Atlanta and who remember
his name was him
Luke Heath stanfield he is so talented
and he was at the very beginning of get
out I believe right yeah and while he
was throughout get out but uh really
great actor in the the film as a whole
is just super inventive and goes to such
bizarre Heights that I don't I can't
even explain it came to putting words
it's just so well done um I'll also give
a shout out to Philip whose birthday it
was yesterday wish him a happy belated
birthday on Twitter it was also the
birthday of one of our editors Aaron
yesterday and he's a great guy so if you
know him wish him a happy birthday too
and one final shout out I'm actually sad
to report that Jon Schnepp has passed
away Jon Schnepp was a filmmaker and a
comedian and host over with our friends
at Collider you may have seen some
videos with mod and Sam have done some
stuff with them on collider heroes and
unfortunately John suffered a stroke
yesterday and he has been on life
support and he passed away earlier today
our thoughts go out to his family and
its close friends and his loved ones he
did what we do here and he did it in
such a fun charming way and he said he
was a super smart super funny guy so
it's a satyr place without him
especially in Comic Con which this is a
time that would be very fun for him to
be around anyway well thank you for
watching this week's episode of new
rockstars news I've been Erich Voss you
can tweet me at ei vas and normally
there will be other hosts here so don't
worry this is not a new change
just this week you can comment down
below tweet us at new rock stars like
this video share it around and subscribe
new rock stars for deep dives and all
the stuff you love we'll catch you next
week with non imaginary friends say bye
Boba Fett
say goodnight baby Groot goodnight